this is a production of cornell
university
um first i just wanted to thank margaret
for inviting me
to this early career seminar it's a
huge honor to be an invited speaker as a
graduate student so i'm super excited to
be able to tell you guys a little bit
about my thesis work studying
protein-protein interactions
in the arabidopsis circadian clock
so circadian rhythms let's see here
circadian rhythms are defined by these
three primary criteria
they're endogenously generated so they
are encoded in the genome
that and they produce 24-hour rhythms
and
are temperature compensated which just
means that these 24-hour rhythms aren't
going to speed up when it gets hot
outside and they're not going to slow
down when the temperature drops
and circadian clocks are present in all
kingdoms of life
and regulate various important
phenotypes so in humans we think of the
sleep wake cycle
in plants we often think of flowering
time and the clock is even in
cyanobacteria to control the timing of
nitrogen fixation
and um in a big win for the plant
biology field
the circadian rhythms were first
identified in plants
in 1729 by this french corona biologist
who noticed this interesting leaf
movement behavior
in one of his plants outside his house
where the leaves lowered and raised
every day and so he did a simple
experiment
where he brought his plant inside his
house into his basement
and put it under constant darkness and
under this condition
he noticed that this leaf movement
behavior continued with
a period of approximately 24 hours and
this was the first evidence that
um that plants had a circadian clock
and so the way this works is that this
plant is given
an input cue from the environment and in
plants that's primarily
day length and temperature cycles which
feed into the core oscillator which i'll
talk about in the next slide
and this oscillator coordinates a
physiological output response which here
is leaf movement
so when you break the clock these
clock regulated outputs are
desynchronized so
leaf movement might have a shorter
period than 24 hours
it might have a longer period or as
shown here it might desynchronize to the
point of arrhythmicity where you
lose rhythms altogether and the clock
controls more than just leaf movement of
course
so cold tolerance flowering time even
biotic stress response and pest
resistance
is clock regulated so all of these
phenotypes are actually
have a time of day component associated
with them
so this um figure
uh represents the core oscillator in
arabidopsis
and so it consists of these interlocking
transcription translation feedback loops
and so i'm not going to walk you through
the very complex signaling pathway
uh pictured here but um what i want to
demonstrate
is that this complex signaling pathway
operates to produce these very precisely
timed
phased patterns of gene expression over
the course of the day
and it's this time of day specific gene
expression
that produces these time of day specific
phenotypes
and one thing about the clock oscillator
is that all of these components
have been identified by forward genetics
and so in the new snow lab we take
a proteomic approach to identify new
circadian clock components
and even connections between
environmental input pathways
and physiological output pathways
and the way we do this is using a method
called affinity purification coupled
with mass spectrometry
and so in this method we're using
arabidopsis
where we've engineered it with a clock
gene of interest
driven by its endogenous promoter and we
add two affinity tags
a 6x histidine tag and a 3x flag tag and
you might hear me refer to this as the
hfc tag
for his flag c terminal and we
engineer this in a clock mutant
background so whatever
gene we're interested in we're
engineering that into the clock mutant
background so our affinity tag version
is the only one
operating in that plant we make protein
extracts from that genetically modified
plant
and we perform two affinity
purifications the first
is purifying for that flag tag and so
our clock protein along with any
interacting protein as represented by
these colored triangles
and that can be a direct interaction or
an indirect interactor
those proteins are co-purified
we perform a second affinity
purification isolating for that his
tag to further cope to further purify
specific interactors for our clock
protein while non-specific binding
proteins
will flow off we've identified
these interacting proteins by mass
spectrometry and then we perform a
quality control step
in which we're subtracting out any
proteins that co-purify
with our negative controls the first of
which is a gfp
with our affinity tag and we also
perform a wild type
no tag control because those experiments
are only going to pull down non-specific
binding proteins that we are not
interested in
so we've performed this method for about
13 of the core circadian clock
components
and along this timeline i'm showing the
time of day that we collected tissue for
each of these proteins
which correspond corresponds to the time
of day of peak protein expression
and for each of our affinity tag blinds
we ensure that they meet two criteria
we first confirm that our hfc version of
the tag
of the protein is operating exactly like
the native protein would
and so for example for rev 8 we have
line 11-3 which rescues the
long circadian mutant phenotype of the
rev 8-1 null mutant
back to wild type levels
another thing that we check before we
can use these lines for affinity
purification
is we do a 24-hour diurnal time course
to look at protein expression over the
course of the day
to ensure that the circadian expression
pattern is
present and also this is how we identify
the time of day that we're going to
collect tissue
for our experiment so for rev 8
it has a maximal peak around 6 hours
after dawn
so we've performed this process for all
of our affinity tagged
lines at this time and i also wanted to
acknowledge
help from our collaborators dr nora hito
nakamichi who provided our
prr five seven and nine lines and dr
andrew miller and dr
uriel or kisa garcia provided the talk
one line
and while i'd love to show you all of
the very interesting things that we
found in all of these lists
today i'm just going to be focusing on
link 1 link 2
and rev8 as those are the core of my
thesis work
so link 1 and 2 are night light
inducible and clock regulated 1 and 2
and they are transcriptional
co-regulators with the activator
transcription factor
revoli8 and together in a complex
these proteins activate the expression
of evening
circadian clock genes and today i
will mention talk 1 and prr5
later in my talk so those are the two
that i want to highlight here
and a previous study demonstrated that
the lynx
performed this coactivation role by
recruiting rna polymerase ii
to rev eight cis regulatory motifs and
target gene promoters called the evening
element
okay so i'm going to jump into a few um
what we found in these affinity
purifications for these three clock
proteins
so in this table the values that you're
seeing are exclusive unique spectra
so these are the spectra that were
identified in the mass spec
for these interacting proteins listed
here and
this is of course a very abbreviated
table i'm just pulling out
four of these cold response proteins
that we noticed were
very high up on our interactor list in
terms of exclusive unique spectra
and so these are tcf1 which stands for
tolerant to chilling
freezing one a family member of tcf1
which is a regulator of chromosome
condensation
family member and then core 27 and core
28 which are cold regulated proteins
and so because we identified these cold
response proteins
so high up on our interactor lists for
this transcriptional complex
we hypothesized that this link rev8
transcriptional complex could act as a
conduit
between the clock and cold temperature
input and
or regulation of cold temperature as an
output of the clock
and recently we got some encouraging
evidence that we were on the right track
so this 2021 paper came out
demonstrating that the revolutes are
positive regulators
of the dreb 1 transcription factor
family
these are also known as the cbfs and so
they demonstrated that
in particular revelli 4 and 8 are
important for
activation of dreb1a and additionally in
figure d you can see that the circadian
rh expression pattern of dreb1a is
severely dampened
um in this rev in these rev mutants
um and they further demonstrated that
this has a
physiological consequence in the plant
so when you
knock out rev408 the plants
perform worse in freezing tolerance
tests
as demonstrated in b and c
okay so when i had this list of proteins
i decided to focus on core 27 and core
28
primarily because when i looked in the
literature i saw that the cores were
already associated with circadian
rhythms
previously so in this 2016 paper
they the authors demonstrated that the
cores have a
long period mutant phenotype when you
knock them out
this is very similar to what we see in
the link mutants
indicating that the cores and the links
could be operating in the clock
in a similar fashion additionally very
excitingly
this paper demonstrated that the cores
are
repressors of prr5 and talk one
those two evening express circadian
clock genes that are
activated by the link rev
transcriptional complex
um and specifically the cores
appear to be repressors of these genes
at the end of the day
towards dusk so there's a time of day
specific component there as well
and just a note that the lynx the link
rev
complex is activating towards more than
midday morning
and then they also demonstrated that the
core mutants exhibit enhanced freezing
tolerance
so these over expression lines here at
the bottom perform worse than
the wild type here while the mutants
perform a little better in these
freezing assays
okay so you might have noticed from my
interaction diagram
that the cores appear to be link one
specific interactors
but we were curious if this was truly a
link one specific
interaction or if we were simply not
seeing the cores in the affinity
purification experiments from rev
8 and link 2 because of the time of day
that we collected tissue for those
experiments
so again we collected tissue based on
the time of day of peak protein
expression
um for our bait proteins and so for link
one that was
nine hours after dawn while rev eight
and link two were collected five hours
after dawn
and so i'm going to represent this
graphically here
so i've mapped onto this figure the
protein expression patterns
based on these 24-hour western blots
that i showed you earlier
just with densitometry analysis for our
circadian clock proteins and if
i overlay onto here the mrna expression
patterns for core 27 and core 28 from
public database you can see that the
cores have
a circadian expression pattern and they
peak towards dusk
about 12 hours after dawn
and if i map onto here the time of day
that we collected tissue for affinity
purification
you can see that at zt5 or 5 hours after
dawn
the cores are barely expressed while
nine hours after dawn
they're much more highly expressed
coming up in the day
and so it's entirely possible that the
time of day that we collected tissue
is influencing our data and so what we
did
was swap the time of day that these
proteins were collected
okay so again in our original experiment
we
did not see any spectra popping up in
our link two and rev8
affinity purifications and then when we
swapped them
we saw exactly the opposite so when rev8
and link two
are collected near the end of the day
core 27 and 28
now appear in their affinity
purifications while link one
lost its interaction with the cores
indicating that
there's a time of day specific component
to this interaction
and this is interesting in the circadian
world because this
kind of narrows down the time of day
that the course could be influencing
clock activity
specifically towards dusk at the end of
the day
okay so the next question we asked was
whether
the links have an uh a
function and using temperature as an
entrainment queue or a synchronization
cue
to the circadian clock
and to answer this question we're using
a luciferase reporter assay
and so that's pictured here where we
have a clock gene promoter
driving the expression of luciferase and
this is just an easy
way to monitor clock activity
so when we're imaging these plants we
first grow them in constant light
so this is a condition in which the
plant has no entrainment cue
um it's relying solely on its circadian
clock to maintain rhythms
we then transfer it into a temperature
cycle condition
where we're providing 12 hours of 22
degrees celsius
and 12 hours at 18 degrees celsius in
which
a wild type plant would be able to use
this
cycling pattern to entrain circadian
rhythms
and our hypothesis is that the link
mutants would not be able to use
temperature cycles as an entrainment
queue
okay so again in this first part of the
experiment
we're in constant light and as i
mentioned in the introduction
link mutants have a long period
phenotype which you can see nicely here
as
these um as the rhythms get further and
further away from the wild type as
represented in black
and to kind of help you look at this
data i've traced on with this dotted
line
the peak expression of wild type
luciferase reporter
and so if you look for example at the
link 2-4 null mutant
you can see that the peak of link 2 gets
further and further
away from wild type because of its long
period phenotype
when we supply these plants with a
temperature entrainment queue
you can see that it takes several days
for these plants to use this information
to entrain their circadian clock and so
i'm going to first walk through
link two in pink and so again
this peak is not overlapping with the
wild type peak
indicating that it's not re-entraining
to type rhythms
by the end of the experiment you can
finally see that link two
has realigned with wild type but it took
several days for it to get to that point
in contrast link one never realigns its
um peak expression with that of wild
type
um indicating that these mutants are
impaired in their ability to use
temperature cycles
as an entrainment queue and i think this
becomes
very apparent when we contrast this to
when uh
when we contrast this to where we're
adding a photo entrainment
cue after providing constant light
so again our link mutants have this long
period phenotype in constant light
and then when we provide just one night
of darkness followed by dawn
lights on the next day you can see that
all the length mutants immediately
re-entrain
their peak expression pattern with that
of wild type
throughout the end of the experiment
indicating that these plants aren't
impaired in general in their ability to
use entrainment cues
to synchronize the clock but it's
specifically a temperature defect
that they're unable to use
okay so based on um
the data that we've gathered so far
we've put together the following model
where in the late morning about five
hours after dawn
link one and two are interacting with
rev8 to fulfill their canonical role as
co-activators of evening expressed rev-8
target genes
like prr5 in the evening
we believe that it's that core 27 and 28
are interacting with this
transcriptional complex to prevent
activation of these target genes
possibly by sequestering
this complex or another mechanism
so the next thing on the horizon is
characterizing the molecular mechanism
of this interaction
so what is the functional consequence of
the core link rev8 interaction
and again we think that binding of the
cores to the link rev complex could
reduce
the binding affinity to target gene
promoters
so two questions that we're going to ask
are can core 27 and 28
bind rev8 target genes without rev8 so
again the cores do not have a dna
binding domain
so we're unsure how these proteins are
associating with these promoters
and we think that rev8 is likely the
intermediate there we also want to know
does rev8 dna binding activity increase
in the absence of the cores
if the cores are engaging in the
sequestering
activity i think we can answer it
we can answer this question both of
these were planning to use chromatin
immunoprecipitation
with qpcr to answer
okay so in summary we've discovered
novel interacting partners for
13 of these core circadian clock
oscillator proteins
using our proteomic approach
we've also identified a time-of-day
dependent interaction between
the link 1 2 rev 8 complex with core 27
and 28
at the end of the day specifically
and third we've identified a role for
the links in temperature and treatment
of the clock
and with that i would like to thank
everyone in the new snow lab
at the danforth plant science center our
collaborators who've
graciously provided reagents and lines
for us
and my thesis committee and i'd be happy
to take any questions
so you can either unmute yourself or if
you have a question that you want to
type into the chat i will read it out
thank you that was really great and also
provides another thing to be concerned
about when you're trying to
look for molecular interactions it's
nice that the
protein and we're also influenced by
time of day
um yeah that's the circadian like
researcher favorite question at a
seminar is like what time did you do
your experiment
so you know it does it does matter
yeah so i um i'm less familiar with the
temperature entrainment i was wondering
are plants that are temperature
entrained
also showing the um circum mutations
the leaf flapping yeah yeah so
even without any um
light dark cycles temperature alone can
entrain
circadian rhythms and leaf movement um
and other
all the other circadian outputs cool
yeah great yeah and if you have any
follow-up questions
um you can contact maria um or if you
haven't
already scheduled yeah that was
fantastic thank you
thank you guys for um listening to my
talk
cool and um now i'll introduce
jim foreigner uh who will tell us about
uh phase change and development so the
the longer term
temporal regulation in plant development
uh yeah thanks margaret sorry there you
go margaret only invites speakers who
like moss and running i think that's
a clear theme and so yeah as margaret
mentioned
um i like to shift from a kind of a
daily proteomics approach into a more
um developmental genetic approach uh
with this talk
and so what i'm really trying to
understand is are developmental clocks
when i talk about developmental clocks
um i'm talking about
the timing of developmental transitions
so
flowering plants go for a series of
different stereotypical transitions as
they progress through their life cycles
from embryogenesis to seed maturation
and following germination from juvenile
to adult periods of vegetative growth
before the onset of flowering the
production of gametes and
the starting of a life cycle again um a
developmental transition
uh i'm actually interested in the potent
labs most interested in
is this switch between a juvenile and an
adult stage of vegetative growth
known as vegetative phase change and
what we're really trying to understand
is
what are the factors that control the
timing of this transition
so in arabidopsis um well depending on
the species
um vegetative phase change is associated
with
a wide variety of traits and arabidopsis
we've got a nice set of diagnostic
features that distinguish between
juvenile and adult phases of development
so juvenile leaves for example
smaller they're rounder they have a
flatter
blade angle and they also lack
serrations
and trichomes on the of actual surface
of the leaf here
whereas adult leaves they're they're
bigger they're longer they have a
narrower blade angle
and they produce serrations and
trichomes uh both on the ad actual
and the ab actual surface of the leaf so
it's
it's a really kind of nice system to
study phase chain phase change
with these different character states
so in arabidopsis uh and all other
surveyed plants
uh vegetative phase change is triggered
by the activity
of spl genes um and spl genes are
characterized by the presence of this
squamosa promoter binding protein box
bit of a mouthful
um and a subset of spl genes are also
targeted by
two micrornas so micron a156 and micron
a157 and
the binding site for these micrornas can
be in the coding um sequence of a
transcript
or in the free prime utr and 156 is
a more effective repressor has more
affinity for the target site for 157
but 157 does a pretty good job as well
so as these micrornas repress
spl genes and spl genes trigger
switch to adult growth we really think
of these micrornas as the master
regulators
of vegetative phase change um
and are eight 156 loci and four 157 loci
narebidopsis
and a subset of these contribute the
most regulation and two in particular
156a and 156c other
kind of crucial regulators and you can
see in a a 156
a c double loss of function mutant
um leaves start to produce ab actual
trichomes shown here
in black a much earlier leaf than in
wild type plants so it's
these are really crucial regulators 156a
and 156c
and during development the expression of
these genes and the
the accumulation of the mature micrornas
decreases
so in this case the mature microrna
decreases most drastically from one to
two weeks of development
and then this decline slows a bit
afterwards
and this accumulation pattern of the
mature microrna is really largely
explained by the expression
of the two primary transcripts a and c
and they have similar but not quite
identical expression patterns in that c
declines a bit more slowly than a
and it's this temporal decline in 156
that really kind of underpins our
understanding of how phase change works
in the
temporal decline in 156 expression leads
to a concomitant increase in the
accumulation
of targets in the spl gene family and
it's this increase in spl products
but triggers the switch from juvenile to
adult growth
and this precedes the subsequent switch
to reproductive growth following
inductive conditions
so it's this temporal decline in 156 is
key but
the factors that regulate this this this
developmental decrease in expression of
a master regulator
are really unknown and it's like it's a
key question in the field is what
controls
the temporal decline in 156 expression
so recently work in the potent lab and
others have shown that epigenetic
silencing of 156 is really crucial to
its expression pattern
so if we look at um the balance between
an active
uh and a repressive histone mark this
active um histomark h3 k27
acetylation um decreases over time
uh it's at the 156c locus from one to
two
to three to five weeks so as 156
expression decreases
it's associated with less of its active
histone mark
and likewise you have an inverse pattern
for this repressive histone mark
h3 k27 trimethylation which increases
gradually
from one to two to three to five weeks
so it looks like there's
this balance of active and repressive
histone marks is uh
critical in the regulation of 156c
um and when it comes to epigenetic
regulation we know that there are a
couple of of key regulators that
coordinate this
in particular the polycon repressive
complexes
one and two and this cartoon just shows
you the
kind of cruci critical components of
prc1 and prc2
and prc1 tends to act through deposition
of another repressive histone mark
h2a ubiquitination and it can also
promote the
activity of prc2 which leads to h3k27
trimethylation so um psa1 and prc2 are
really critical factors in epigenetic
silencing
and it looks like they also function in
phase change as well
so lots of ps but prc2 component curly
leaf
which compo encodes a mephile
transferase
loss of this g leads to a significant
that can decrease
in the deposition of h3k 27
trimethylation
and an associated increase in the
expression
of 156 and likewise loss of the prc1
components
80 bmi 1ab these two redundant
ebicketinases
leads to a significant decrease in the
deposition of h2aub
and also h3k27 trimethylation
so you've got prc1 and prc2 appear
critical to the
silencing of 156
so to kind of summarize what we know
about the temporal regulation of 156
we know its expression decreases over
time and this is critical to the
regulation of the timing of phase change
we know that the expression of 156 a and
c these two critical loci is associated
with an active histone mark
and is uh repression is associated with
two
additional histone marks and that prc1
and prc2 are critical in the in the
repression of 156 so this is the kind of
our understanding of how 156 is
regulated at the moment
but what we don't know is what is the
temporal signal that leads to the
gradual repression of 156
so we know that epigenetic silence thing
is important we know it's the
coordination of two different
antagonistic interaction of different
histone marks but we don't know what the
temporal signal is
but triggers the replacement of an
active histone mark
by a repressive one and that's really
what i'm i've been trying to investigate
the last couple of years and what
this project is all about
so a couple of good candidates for for
components that might supply this
temporal signal that are val genes
and so val genes um are b3 domain
transcription factors
and there's three valgine's arabidopsis
at which two are two are most important
and val 1 and val 2 were originally
identified
in their role in a pre a kind of
preceding developmental transition
in how they repress embryogenesis so
loss of val 1 and val 2
leads to the continuous production of
embryogenic ally at both the
shoot and root apical meristems so if
you lose malfunction
you don't repress embryogenesis
um our kind of best understanding now of
how biogenes function
is via a subsequent developmental
transition out of flowering
and we know that um val genes bind to
their targets these are
why sites at the flc
locus flora floral repressor
and when valgens bind to our y sites
they promote the activity here
predominantly of prc2
which leads to the deposition of h3k27
trimethylation
and flc the repression flc and the uh
transition to flowering so um they're
crucial regulators of different
developmental transitions throughout the
life cycles of plants
and we've got a bit of an indication
that they might function phase change in
that
loss of val 1 and val2 also lead to a
reduction
in h3 k27 at 156 a
and c so
we know valgene's interact with prc1 and
prc2 they're involved in developmental
timing
or developmental transitions throughout
the life cycle of plant and they have
somewhat of a role here
at a anc in terms of air regulation
so it looks like potentially they were
pretty good candidates for maybe
supplying
this temporal signal into the regulation
of phase change
and while that work was going on and to
try and understand how value genes are
functioning at other transitions
i was carrying out an ems mutagenesis
screen
to try and identify some novel
regulators phase change
and i found this lovely cute little uh
juvenilized plant it's got lots of nice
small round leaves
it's got a significant delay in the
timing of phase change
um and mapping this mutation reeled it
to be
unsurprisingly in val one um and this
mutation leads to the conversion of a
um really very conserved arginine
residue
right in the b3 domain of the dna
binding domain
um and so it's it's a very crucial
mutation in an important part of the
protein
and we've called it semi-dominant
because um even in the heterozygous form
we have we see a significant delay in
the timing of phase change so it was
quite a quite a nice mutation to find
so with all this in mind what i want to
do is kind of
what i have done is systematically
tested whether val gene supply of this
temple signal whether they have a
fundamental core
temporal regulator a vegetative phase
change
so to do this the first thing i wanted
to to test was whether val genes have a
temporal effect on on vegetative
development on the phenotype
of of plants so to do this i combined
um my nice new val1 uh mutation
uh and other another null tdnaval one
with uh several different vowel two uh
tda insertions to get over a problem of
redundancy between val 1 and val 2.
and you can see here that perhaps that
these two different val1
single mutants have uh have an effect on
on phase change they are significantly
delayed in the terms of
the timing of trichome production it's
relatively subtle
uh val ii um single mutants
take my word for have no effects on on
phase change
when you combine what val 1 and val 2 to
make doubles in all three cases you see
some really nice
delayed phase change phenotypes these
are really juveniles plants
particularly in the case of isoval 1-2
val 2-1
all the leaves this guy is producing
small around they look very similar to
the first two leaves
of wild-type plants so it's suggesting
that valentine's really are critical
regulators of vegetative phase change
um and trying to get a handle on whether
they've got a temporal effect
i quantified the the length width ratio
of leaf blades in these various
different mutant lines
so in wild type plants in silver here
you see a gradual increase
in the ratio between the length and the
width of the blade so as
more adult leaves get longer uh in val
one single mutants you see somewhat of a
suppression of this because they're
juveniles their leaves appear
um shorter around it for longer
and an even bigger effect in val one
val2 doubles
and it's at a later lease stage but you
really see these effects to manifest
themselves so it looks like they are
at least temporarily regulating the
phenotype of phase change
so the next kind of obvious thing i
wanted to test was whether um
val genes are regulating the temporal
expression pattern of 156
and so i quantified rna levels in these
different mutant plants
and in wild type you can see here again
in silver it's very characteristic
temporal decline from one to two to
three weeks of both 156
and 157 and for the val 1 single and
also with l1
5 l2-3 double you see a
a general increase in the amount of
these micrornas
particularly for the double mutant here
but
surprisingly to us the temporal pattern
is remarkably consistent so even though
we've
really strongly eliminated male activity
you see an elevation of 156 and 157
levels
you still see this very robust um
temporal pattern
which was i'll tell you a little
disappointing but nonetheless that's
what it was
um so the next thing i wanted to test
was okay well they don't val 1 val2
don't appear to have
they're not necessary for the temporal
decline in 156 but do they affect the
temporal um patterns of stone deposition
that i've talked about
so the first thing i tested was uh
effectively the activity of prc2
via h3k27 trimethylation and in this
case at the 156c
locus so this is a schematic of 156c and
you can see that
dotted along the 156c locus r5r y sites
which are
with dna binding sites for valjeans
and in terms of h3k27 deposition
in wild type again in silver you see
this very nice characteristic temporal
increase
in the deposition of its histone mark
and in the val one val2 double
you see you do see a nice attenuation
actually of this this temporal increase
so it does appear like
belgians are important for the temporal
pattern or temporal deposition of
h3k27
so i also wanted to check how prc one
activity is regulated
and to do this i looked at the h2a
ubiquitin mark and unlike h3k27
you don't see a temporal increase in
this markets it's kind of flat lines
across development
uh very interestingly in the val1 val2
double losser function line
you see a significant difference
throughout development
and this is kind of really important in
terms of how we understand epigenetic
silencing in plants in the
the kind of canonical model of prc
activity from animals
is that prc2 activity so h3k27
precedes the activity of prc1 whereas
what we see
here and this is a kind of emerging
model implants is that really
prc1 activity um precedes that of prc2
and that's
kind of mechanistically shown here at
this specific locus in that you see a
significant difference
at one week for prt one activity but
that doesn't manifest itself until three
weeks
for prc2 so that kind of nicely supports
um
other findings in the field of
epigenetic regulation
so the next thing i want to test in
terms of whether valve one is temporally
regulating 156 is
well does val one actually have a
template binding pattern to 156 loci
so to do this i used an h a tagged
version of the val one protein
and looked for a chip qpcr analysis of
val1 binding over time so this graph
shows you
effectively the affinity of val one for
the 156c locus
in white is the uh wild type negative
control
and in grey the um temporal series from
one to two to three weeks of l1 binding
and what this shows is that firstly val
one has a different affinity for
different regions at the 156 c locus and
it
binds particularly strongly around this
r y site and
this area of the gene but there is no
temporal pattern of l1 binding again
slightly surprisingly it's
kind of pretty pretty flat affinity
during vegetative development which was
again not what we were expecting to find
to to further get a handle on how
um val genes interact with the 156c
locus i went about interfering with the
binding site the ry binding sites
so i took a five kilobase fragment of
the 156c locus
and removed each of the five ry sites
individually
and also all five ry sites in
combination
and i took these different um fragments
and transformed them into a
156 ac 157 ac
quadruple mutant background so this
quadruple mutant background
has uh all pretty much 156 and 157
activity eliminated
so it's really nice background to do
these experiments because it's very
sensitive
to any um perturbations to 156 levels
so you can see that in a quad this
quadruple mutant background these plants
produce trichomes very early on about
leaf three in the empty vector control
yeah there's no effect
in a nice positive control here we have
is the
triple mutant where you you've got a
functional 156c
so in here you've got the endogenous
156c locus is intact
and you can tell that having this
endogenous 156c locus
delays development to about trichome
production to about at least five
so when i take a 156c fragment with all
our y sites intact
intact and transform that you see the
same behavior effectively as the triple
mutant so that's a nice endorsement to
show
that okay the wild type 156c fragment
i'm taking behaves
like the endogenous locus deletion of
all five
ry sites individually significantly
delays the timing of
actual trichome production and when all
five are why sites are deleted
in combination you see an even greater
delay in the timing of
actual trichome production showing that
all five
ry sites are functional um
and that it's val one even though we
don't see a temporal
path taps pattern for val one while one
is certainly
affecting um 156 activity
again to investigate um this kind of
temporal relationship between belgians
and 156 levels
i quantified um rna levels in these
different
genetic backgrounds so in the triple
mutant as
you expect you see this temporal decline
in 156 levels
because you still have this endogenous
156 c
for the wild site version of 156c in the
quadruple map
mutant background you see this temple
decline and this is there's quite a lot
of variation here because these are
different independent
um homozygous insertions
but when you remove a single roi site
perhaps the most important ry site and
all five rye sites together
you see a bit of a bump in terms of 156
levels
but again you see this really consistent
temporal decline in 156 levels so this
supports the earlier results from the
loss of function studies in the
val genes on or val activity isn't
necessary for the temporal decline
in 156 activity
so i also wanted to make sure that these
results what i what i see here is
because of
an interaction between loss of r y sites
and val one itself
um so i uh introgressed the loss of val
one mutation
into these different mutant lines to
test for an interaction between
the 156 locus and valon itself
so as you'd expect in a triple mutant
and where we have the wild type version
of the 156c
locus loss of val 1 leads to a
significant delay
in the timing of trichome productions
because you still have all these ry
sites intact
surprisingly when i also introduced val1
into lines that don't have ry sites so
you think there's nowhere for val 1 to
bind so you shouldn't see an effect of
loss of val1 function
you still see a significant delay in the
timing of actual trichome production
so even when there's nowhere for l1 to
bind not
losing vowel 1 activity still delays
phase change
and so the most obvious interpretation
of this data for us i think
is that as well as functioning through
156 vowel
genes are regulating phase change via
156
independent mechanisms and so
to test this and this is the final piece
of this puzzle um
i uh combine the vowel one
loss of function mutation with the
quadruple mutant where you haven't got
any 156 and 157
and the kind of gross morphology of
early development
shows that the quadruple mutant
phenotype is largely epistatic
if you look at the developments
certainly of leaf one and two and the
rate of leak initiation
it looks largely like the quadruple
mutant plant itself
suggesting that the activity of val1 is
largely mediated
by 1.56
but when you look at the developmental
time series of leaf development
you we see but actually yeah there is an
independent role
for about a 156 independent role for val
activity
so in this case i'm looking at the angle
of the blade base
so more adult leaves of wild type plants
have a smaller blade base angle because
they get
narrower the vowel one mutation by
itself
elevates this it's got a nice flatter
base angle in the quadruple mutant in
where this is cyan teal whatever color
this is
um it's got a much narrower blade angle
but when you introduce the valve one
mutation you do see an effect even when
there isn't
any uh 156 activity so this is showing
really
confirms that vowel genes are regulating
phase change via 156 pathway
and also independent of 156
and get an idea of what might be going
on here
i introduced a 156 resistant version
of spl9 which is our favorite spl 9 gene
has the biggest effect on phase change
into val1 backgrounds so any effect on
this transgenic reporter is indicative
of a regulatory interaction that has
nothing to do with 156 because 156 can't
regulate
this modified uh transgene so in wild
site plants
you see a very strong expression of this
resistant
resistant reporter throughout
development
being a val-1 background two different
alleles here you see a large suppression
of the reporter both in terms of um
the gus staining and also the actual
kind of delayed
leaf initiation phenotype here as well
so this suggests that
um the 156 independent
role of vowel genes is at least in part
mediated
by a transcription or regulation of spl
genes themselves
independent of 156.
so just to kind of conclude um
so it seems like valgens really function
largely as general
rather than temporal regulators of
and so we can explain our phenotypes i
think if you're looking at
if phase change occurs at a certain
ratio
of active to repressive histone marks at
the 156
locus and it's this balance here and
wild type plants
this is the kind of ratio replacement
and inval mutant plants
you still see the same temporal pattern
of of epigenetic silencing but it's just
um
shifted a little bit in terms of time
secondly that the
temporal expression pattern of 156 a and
c is remarkably robust so
you get rid of all activity you get rid
of val one binding sites
um you get what i haven't shown you here
if you get rid of prc2 components in a
val one background
you still see this remarkable temporal
decline in 156 expressions so it looks
like
plants have evolved a really robust
mechanism for buffering 156 expressions
so it
appears very important to plants that
156 and c have this
this temporal pattern of expression
thirdly that prc1 precedes prc2 and like
i mentioned this is
important in terms of our understanding
of how epigenetic silencing works in
plants and how it makes it different to
animals
and lastly the biogenes regulate um
phase change via 156 dependent and
independent mechanisms
um and this is kind of consistent wait
so so valgean is a function of multiple
nodes at the phase change regulatory
pathway and this is also the case
in embryogenesis they act at different
levels and in flowering
time they act at different levels of the
flowering time pathway as well so it
looks like valgens
although they aren't necessary for the
temporal regulation of 156
have been co-opted uh into a variety of
different genetic networks in the
control of the timing of
of developmental type transitions for
our plant life cycles they're really
um central kind of hubs in in timing
mechanisms
and with that i'd just like to say
thanks this is a very outdated picture
of the poetic lab and thanks in
particular to scott
um and to victoria here who was a
technician who was helping me with this
project and also to
lovely simone and albert einstein who
was helping me with some proteomics on
this study that i
haven't had time to talk about today and
if you have any questions i'd be happy
to take them
thank you jim um that was
that was valid got it fun
that was great um i think mike has lots
of questions
uh he put him in the chat but i see he's
unmuted himself so i'll just let him ask
directly
yeah i guess the i'm wondering whether
or not the val 1
2 doubles really have a more severe
phenotype than val one
alone so i saw there's variation in
those
allele combinations of foul one to
double alleles and seems like
even some that had two exon insertions
in either gene
like this one on the far right bottom
was not as severe as the one in the
middle
val one dash two what's yeah that's one
so what's this variation yes that's a
good question so this is
also why we think that this val one
allele is semi-dominant
um so if you compare so the vowel 1-2 is
a null t dna
but the vowel 1-5 is ems mutation is
just a single base change but has
as as single mutants has a much more
severe phenotype than the tdna
null but when you make double mutants
with val2
you see a much stronger phenotype when
you have the val 1-2 null t dna
and so really it's these two look more
severe
than than this one it's these two blue
lines of l1-2s
and this blue line is a val 1-5 so what
we think's going on
in the vowel 1-5 is that it's a mutation
in the b3
domain it's affecting how val 1 is
binding to
its ry sites and as well as doing that
it's interfering with how
val 2 is binding to our y sites
when it's a single mutant it's got a
stronger effect but when you eliminate
vowel 2 activity
actually it's not as strong because it's
not interfering with val2 because it's
not there
so it's really the two null t dnas that
have a bigger effect
in the double form if that makes sense
that makes sense and then the other
question was uh
this uh this drop in these repressive
histone markers do you see that also in
val one single mutants i may have missed
that
in in in the chromatin state sorry yeah
yeah now um i haven't looked at the
single mutants just because
yeah i wanted to check i wanted to
actually find something
so yeah that's something nice talk you
should submit this uh to facet
i could yeah you already have a bit of a
phase change heavy plenary speaker i
think
um jim i also had a question oh
um yeah i was curious what photo period
you were doing these experiments under
and
if you think that changing to like a
short day long day
would influence the temporal patterns of
mirror of the mri rnas
yeah for sure that's a good question so
um we do
certainly for kind of whenever we're
testing from one week to two weeks to
three weeks
we have to do it in short day conditions
um
predominantly because i have adopted
flowers so early so you know if
aerobiologists
transition to an inflorescence meristem
about leaf you know day 11 day 12 so
very early
so we want to suppress flowering in our
developmental time series to eliminate
that from kind of being a mitigating
factor
so we always grow these in short days
because in short days at one week and
two weeks and three weeks
visa these plants remain strictly
vegetative
so that's very important to us but also
yeah um day length has an effect on 156
expression itself
and you see um both in terms of light
quantity and like quality um it
longer and more like represses 156
and so it appears that maybe this is
something some physiological work going
on in the lab actually by a phd student
who's just finished up and
she's really been investigating how
phase change is an adaptive response to
light conditions and how
um younger plants are better at using
different um
conditions with less light so i think
it's that's kind of related to that
this shows it okay cool thanks cool
thanks nice
yeah getting two temporal people in the
room together
um let's make things yeah
more complex so i was wondering um mere
156 is one of the most
uh conserved micro rna families in land
plants
um are vowels also
super conserved and how um
how broadly present are these ry
sites like are they does it seem like
valves are targeting
i don't know 50 genes or
are they targeting thousands of genes
and and
kind of broadly regulating the genome
yeah so uh the chips seek analysis came
out
last year i think it was um looking at
val one binding across the genome yeah
and it comes out with a lot of targets
so there are ry sites are only
six base pairs sequencing so you're
going to get them pretty heavily
distributed throughout the genome
um in terms of the
there's a very specific interaction
between our y sites and
the free domain transcription factors so
valgene's are part of a much
bigger um family but it's only really
valgens and their sister clade
judispree abi3 and lec ii which
regulated with embryogenesis
to actually bind our y site so it's a
very unique interaction between a
relatively small set of transcription
factors
in our y sites but i think yeah this
explains why
val ones are so um
have such important roles throughout
plant development at various different
stages
um is it you know it's a relatively
simple genetic interaction so it's kind
of been easy i think to coop them
into regulating embryogenesis phase
change flowering time
probably other developmental transitions
as well
i can't tell you how conserve algines i
mean all flowering plants have got them
outside the flowering plants
i'll wait or wait until i start working
on moss and i can tell you
but i mean yeah i mean the evolutionary
role of 156 is something i'm that's what
i'll be doing in bristol that's really
that's an exciting kind of avenue what's
156 doing in plants that don't make
leaves
we like organs but yeah
great are there any other questions
well thank you to both our speakers
please
take them out to maybe do a clap emoji
or or
turn on your video and thank maria and
jim for
excellent seminars today um
yeah it was great to hear about your
work and
catch up with both of you thanks
margaret thanks for having us
but you have some great comments yeah
thanks thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu